hey guys it is the knife that December
today my name is just McDonald and
you're watching games but news follow
Bioware dev Damion Schubert reckons we
should get on board with free to play
the news comes as Schubert prepares to
give a presentation next year at GDC on
y star wars the old republic moved to a
free-to-play model his presentation
called free-to-play is not necessarily
evil will focus on the success they
found with the model and how success
essentially comes down to players
falling in love with your game schubert
does stress however that there is a
right and the wrong way to implement
free-to-play bill Spencer's comments on
the exclusivity of street fighter 5 to
PlayStation 4 continue today the Xbox
exactly said that he will make amends to
xbox one fans over Sony's exclusivity
deal it was suggested to him on Twitter
that for a new banjo kazooie or conquer
game to hit the market gamers wouldn't
mind so much to which he replied love
the idea of game franchise bartering
I'll work on making amends for SF we
already found out that rise of the Tomb
Raider was set to be exclusive for Xbox
one but now we also know it's going to
be published by Microsoft this means
that Microsoft is providing support
across the entire development and
publishing pipeline for the tomb raider
sequel the news has been confirmed by
marketing manager for Xbox are in
Greenburgh there has currently been no
comment from Square Enix about how this
might affect the game's release on other
platforms rise of the Tomb Raider is
currently slated for a holiday 2015
release window as your question of the
day let me know if rise of the Tomb
Raider looks like a game you would pick
up an xbox one for if you're looking for
more stories you can head to gamespot
where we've got bits and pieces on a
brand new tech and character and take to
commenting on the gt5 australia fiasco
that is it for me today i'll be back
same time tomorrow so i hope to capture
them